you don't want to get the vaccine huh
yeah yeah is that right
well too bad no more mr nice politician
you keep resisting that vaccine and don
cuomo leone is going to come on over to
your house and make you an offer you
can't refuse
we have to get in those communities and
we have to knock on those doors
and we have to convince people and put
them in a car
and drive them and get that vaccine in
their arm
that is the mission we're going to load
them up in a car
we're go that's my father k and luca
brazzy's
cuomo is not the only governor who's
demanding that you take the jab covid
cases
are reportedly soaring and apparently
it's all because of vaccine hesitancy
but the problem you see with the lib's
new strategy
of blaming vaccine hesitancy is that the
leading cause of vaccine hesitancy
is thugs like andy cuomo i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from joe mcafee
not to be confused with john mcafee who
definitely did not kill himself joe
writes
didn't i hear last week that those most
hesitant to get the vaccine
are people of color why isn't this guy
being called out the one who's arguing
about vaccine hesitancy
for his blatant racism well you see
because there are different sets of
standards depending on
how you identify in this culture gone
mad
you know in this culture gone mad it's
very important to protect
yourself and your property which is why
i would strongly recommend american home
shield i recently became a homeowner you
know being in la
you live in a cardboard box but then
moved to the south
got a home and that's great it's really
great i really love it
except that homes are money pits and
things
break and no one likes to think about
household breakdowns
but they happen they happen way more
often than you would like certainly
more often than i would like which is
why it pays to have a plan from american
home shield
to help cover the costs to repair and
replace things like your ac
or your fridge american home shield
members get more
more coverage options and fewer
exclusions from
hvac systems and plumbing to kitchen
appliances
their plans help protect parts of up to
23 essential home systems and appliances
in just the past few months
i've had breaks on i think all of those
categories
as a matter of fact so right now to
celebrate 50 years of providing
homeowners peace of mind
you can take fifty dollars off their
most comprehensive plans ever
go to ahs.com knowles save
fifty dollars that is ahs.com
knowles for fifty dollars off any plan
do it right now you will thank me
lighter service fees limitations and
exclusions apply
c plan for details american home shield
be sure with shield
andy cuomo who famously mishandled the
infamously mishandled the coronavirus
and killed thousands of senior citizens
needlessly by shipping six people
sick people into nursing homes and then
covered it up and hid it from federal
investigators
but thankfully then for him joe biden
got into office and then nixed the
federal investigation andy cuomo
is going to show up to your house load
you up in a car
and then stick a needle in your arm and
he's not the only one who's threatening
to do that governor bateman in
california governor gavin newsom mr
nussolini
is also getting in on the act is it time
governor to bring back a universal mass
mandate uh regardless of vaccination
status there in california
look we don't even have to have that
debate if we can just get everybody
vaccinated that's not vaccinated that's
refusing to get vaccinated this living
uh vaccine free and impacting the rest
of us it's like drunk drivers you don't
have the right to go out and drink and
drive and put everybody else at risk
including your own life at risk
what's funny about this explanation that
he's giving this analogy that he's
making
is how stuffy he sounds does bateman
does governor bateman have the
coronavirus he
i don't know you're hearing a lot of
stories now
about huge numbers of people who were
vaccinated now getting
the virus anyway i personally know
people who got vaccinated and then they
just get the virus anyway
but you have to get it because it's very
very important even though it doesn't
work so you gotta
wear the mask anyway and we'll keep you
posted on what the science says tomorrow
what uh governor newsom is saying that's
right newsom that's his name
what he's saying is that if you do not
receive the experimental drug
for the virus that poses a very very low
threat to a lot of people
then it's basically like you're drunk
driving and you'd and the point he's
making is that
there are you know externalities to your
behavior when you're talking about
health this is kind of the premise of
public health
and so the state has a right to go in
and enforce certain health measures and
i actually agree with that
in principle i think a lot of
conservatives would agree with that in
principle
you hear all of these comparisons being
made to the to smallpox or polio
or to the bubonic plague for goodness
sakes
the issue is not so much the principle
as it is the particular because the
woofloo is not
bubonic plague the wufou wuflu is not
polio
and by the way the public health
professionals and the politicians
who have been ordering us around for the
past year and a half
have gotten a lot of things wrong gotten
most things wrong
the issue here is the particulars does
the state
have credibility to order me to take
this experimental drug
now for a virus that poses a very very
infinitesimally small risk
to huge numbers of people it poses a
greater risk to some people
but to most people very low risk
newsome's not the i don't i don't want
to seem
overly partisan here it's not just
newsom and cuomo that are doing this
even some republican governors are
getting in on the action
notably the squish governor of arkansas
asa hutchinson who's going on jake
tapper's show on cnn tells you
everything you need to know about him
to to convince people to go get vaxxed
this is a pivotal moment in our
race against the covet virus we have
school coming up
we have a lot of sports activities that
people are expecting and anxious about
and is important for
normalcy and what's holding us back is a
low vaccination rate we're doing
all that we can and i made the decision
that it's really not
what the government can tell you to do
but it is
the community and their engagement
and citizens talking to other citizens
and trust advisors whether it's
medical community or whether it's
employers
those are key that's why i'm having
these town hall meetings it's more than
listening
it is really engaging the community and
so far we've seen a 40
increase in our vaccinations since we
started this
our goal get information out help them
to make the right decision
push the vaccination and uh hopefully
we'll be ready for school
within the next month so this guy's got
a lighter touch
obviously than newsom who is
calling the people who are skeptical of
the experimental drug
you know drunk drivers who's comparing
them to them and
andrew cuomo who's threatening to go
knock down your house and break your
kneecaps and
and then wear your kneecaps once stood
inject you with the vaccine so
hutchinson
is saying well we're engaging with the
community
and okay fine you'll recall that asa
hutchinson
is the republican governor of arkansas
who defended
transing the kids he said that it was
very important that we
continue to allow pervert parents to
mutilate their children and
inject them with cross-sex hormones and
all this sort of stuff so he's not
exactly
the authority on conservative political
philosophy
but it's not even just the squishes we
actually are at a turning point i don't
think it's a turning point on covid and
the fight against the wufalu or whatever
but i do think it's a turning point
on the way that people are going to be
talking about this vaccine
because now even the republicans are
really going along with this
and even the conservative republicans
are so k ivy
who's the governor down in alabama
generally speaking a very conservative
woman
she has harsh words for people who are
not getting the vaccine she says that we
need to start blaming them
for the spread of the virus let's be
question clear about this issue
maybe i want you to start reporting the
facts
the new cases encoding are because of
unvaccinated votes almost 100
of the new hospitalizations are with
unvaccinated folks
and the deaths are certainly
occurring with unvaccinated folks these
folks are choosing
a horrible lifestyle
self-inflicted pain you know we've got
to get folks
to take the shot vaccine was the
greatest weapon we have to fight colby
there's no question about that
the data proves it i've taken the shot
that can be some both shots and it's
just the thing to do so
the unvaccinations that we need to focus
on y'all get them
to start taking the shot it's their job
to take care of themselves and us as
well
we can't do that farm all we can do is
everybody take the shot themselves
so encourage others to do likewise so
k ivy not mincing words i mean elsewhere
she said
almost i think explicitly blame blame
the unvaccinated if
if uh the cases continue to spike so
what's going on here
why the big switch because for a long
time you heard republicans saying well
people make whatever choices they want
ron desantis is now
strongly encouraging people to get
vaccinated at all age levels
he's still got a lighter touch than
cuomo and newsome but still saying go
out there get vaccinated why
i think the reason is politically
there's no
upside to telling people to make a
prudential judgment
what's the upside to that you're going
to be blamed if the covid cases spike
you're going to be blamed
for any death whatsoever forget about
deaths from
heart disease overdose suicide cancer
any sort of other those deaths you're
not going to be blamed for but one
person dies from coronavirus
you're going to be blamed for that if
you're a governor especially if you're a
republican governor
so there's no upside to telling people
not to get vaccinated also because
if someone does face a side effect from
the vaccine and there have been plenty
of documented cases of that
the cdc and the fda admit that but if
there
will be it's going to be so covered up
by the media
that you're you're probably not going to
face a lot of blame for that so all of
the political pressure
is in the direction of telling people to
go get vaccinated and yet
there are still a lot of people who
don't want to do it
and as kay ivey is saying the all the
numbers of people dying and being
hospitalized with from coronavirus are
among the unvaccinated people
but notice they're not getting more
specific they're not saying it's
unvaccinated 25 year olds
you know it's unvaccinated 30 year olds
no i because
the people who are at greatest risk here
are much much older
or they have lots of comorbidities so
even still you have this prudential
judgment if you're 80 years old should
you get the vaccine
i don't know if i were 80 years old i'd
probably be leaning strongly in that
direction
if you're 15 years old do you need to
get the vaccine i don't know if i were
15 years old
i probably would not be leaning in that
direction although for 15 year olds
obviously their parents are
and their schools and other people are
going to have a huge say over that sort
of thing
and the new york times is doing its best
to ramp up
the blame game so the new york times
has a new article out quote
the delta variant is the symptom of a
bigger threat
vaccine refusal i'm glad at least
they're acknowledging
that there are bigger threats than the
delta variant goodness sakes
because we were told for a year and a
half that covet is the single greatest
threat to
anyone ever in the history of the world
now we've got the delta vids the indian
variant
and from that from the data it seems
that the delta variant is actually less
deadly than the original covid virus
though perhaps it's more transmissible
but they're admitting yeah there's a
greater threat
the greater threat is people not doing
what we tell them to do
here's the tweet americans have been
hearing for months about the threatening
frightening rise of the delta variant
but the virus is not the root cause of
surging infection rates in parts of the
country
vaccine refusal and hesitancy are to
blame
okay fine let's say that let's just go
with your premise new york times that
the real threat here
is not so much the the variant as the
vaccine refusal because the vaccine is
going to do a great job at stopping the
spread of the variant
even though we're also told the vaccine
doesn't do very much so you got to wear
a mask and you got to stop going places
whatever what is the cause of
vaccine refusal and hesitancy
what is the cause of that because as our
commenter pointed out at the top of the
show
black people are disproportionately
likely to be skeptical of the vaccine
and to refuse to take the vaccine
this is never mentioned in any of the
mainstream media coverage here
but and why for instance would black
people in particular
be hesitant to get the vaccine well as
even the left-wing media will admit
because there have been very dodgy
public health professionals in the
history of this country
who have pushed experimental drugs on
black people and it hasn't redounded
always to their benefit why would people
generally be hesitant to get the vaccine
is it because they're dumb idi the idiot
percentage as that msnbc guy said
yesterday
because they're deplorable irredeemable
bitter clinging bible
or is it because the public health
professionals and the politicians and
the media
have lied to them every step of the way
they lied to them about 15 days to slow
the spread they lied to them about the
the virus occurring naturally in bats
they lied to them about the virus coming
from the wuhan wet market
they lied to them about the the leak
from the wuhan laboratory they lied to
them
about funding from the united states and
from nina
nhiad and dr fauci and the nih generally
they lied to them about everything and
so they don't have credibility and so
when those
same people those dishonest
corrupt inept people tell them hey
you've got to get the vaccine
guess what the reaction's going to be no
go take a long walk off a short bridge
are you kidding me absolutely not and
it's not
their fault it is not the fault of the
black people or the fault of the
deplorables or the fault of the rural
idiot percentage american whatever you
want to call them
it's your fault new york times and it's
your fault dr fauci
and it's your fault political
establishment
that has squandered your credibility
so i don't want to hear it i don't want
to hear from the new york times i don't
believe them
i'm extremely skeptical when they tell
me that the delta variant's a big threat
and it's surging and it's the cases and
everyone needs to i just i just don't
believe them
and my disbelief is not my fault my
disbelief is rational
because you guys don't have any
credibility
they're going to use every means at
their disposal by the way to get
everyone regardless of age regardless of
risk regardless of circumstance to take
the shot
bill de blasio going back up to
to our thug friends in new york state
bill de blasio the mayor of new york
is lamenting the fact that they're not
going to institute a mandate
at the state level at the city level
it's just not politically viable
so instead what bill de blasio wants is
for businesses
to institute mandates to force people to
get the shot
we announced this week that we are
mandating
uh that everyone who works in our public
hospitals
either has to get vaccinated one time
you know when you're fully vaccinated
you're done
or has to be tested every week for covet
we'll give you every chance but if you
don't agree with one of those things
then you're suspended without pay
i'm calling upon all new york city
employers
and including our private hospitals move
immediately to some form of mandate uh
whatever the maximum you feel you can do
any form of mandate including the type
we're doing you know the either or
approach
any type of mandate helps it will move
the ball it will get more people
vaccinated it will change consciousness
so we have reached the limits of a
purely voluntary system it's time for
more
mandates bill de blasio
basically wakes up saying this in the
middle of the night since he was a child
it's time for more mandates we need
there's nothing a mandate can't fix
need demand covado sure we need a covid
mandate so he
he obviously wants to mandate these
things another
argument for skepticism here of the
vaccine etc
and i'm just i'm just describing to you
why people are skeptical of this i'm not
even making the tightest
soundest most logical argument i'm just
making an observation bill de blasio is
wrong
about everything he's wrong about
absolutely everything he's wrong about
human nature
he's wrong about the way that the
citizen should relate to the state he's
wrong about metaphysical things he's
wrong about physical things he's wrong
about abortion he's wrong about
immigration he's wrong about
the economy he's wrong about everything
he's wrong about everything
and he's really really insistent that
you get the jab
same goes for cuomo same goes for pelosi
same goes now
you're beginning to see some republicans
it'll be a little bit more encouraging
but i'm just if you're the average
ordinary person you don't have a ton of
time to pay a lot of attention to
politics
and you see that the people and the
institutions who are most insistent that
everybody regardless of risk throw their
prudence out the window and just
get the jab that that all of those
people and institutions
are wrong about everything else it is
perfectly
rational and natural for you to say huh
maybe they're wrong about this too
i'm not saying they necessarily are
wrong about this too but i'm just
explaining i'm just observing why people
might be slow
to get it and and you can see here the
means by which
the the left is going to do this and and
by the way it's not even just about the
vaccine
this is the the vaccine and the public
health dictatorship is just a very clear
example
of the broader problem of the blob of
the liberal establishment
that is going to use not just the force
of government but the force
of every tentacle that this that this
animal has
to to control you and shape your
behavior and get you to bend to its will
so de blasio says yeah okay we're not
going to be able to do this at the city
level so
i'm calling on all businesses to do my
will
i'm calling on all businesses to act as
proxies enforcement arms
for the liberal state and this is what
the establishment does it's not just the
government you know
there was a an announcement yesterday
one of the most terrifying announcements
to come out of the liberal establishment
surveillance state in quite some time
paypal is teaming up with the adl
the adl is the quote-unquote
anti-defamation league it's a
far-left hideous organization that
should be banished from the country
the paypal is teaming up with the adl to
suppress quote unquote
hate movements what's a hate movement
i think to according to the adl anybody
slightly to the right of hillary clinton
constitutes a hate movement
paypal is teaming up with the adl to
quote uncover and disrupt the financial
pipelines
that support extremist and hate
movements
okay this according to a joint statement
both from paypal and the adl
the initiative will focus on white
supremacists you know all those white
suprema i think
there are about seven white supremacists
in the country they all work for the fbi
they're all just informing on each other
but it's gonna it's going to
focus on the white supremacists the
anti-government
organizations and that anti-government
is in quotes in the state which is very
strange
and those propagating and profiting from
anti-semitism islamophobia racism
anti-immigrant anti-black anti-hispanic
and anti-asian hate well hold on here
let's
let's just pause so white supremacy that
word doesn't mean anything anymore
anti-government organization are we are
we anti-government
i'm anti-this government i'm not
anti-government per se i'm not an
anarchist but i'm anti-discover so i
guess
okay i checked that box uh let's see
anti-semitic i'm not anti-semitic
islamophobic what is islam
like an irrational i don't think it's an
irration i'm not muslim
i don't support an islamic takeover of
the west i guess so i guess
i guess i checked that box racism again
that word doesn't mean anything anymore
anti-immigrant well i think we should
drastically reduce immigration both
legal and illegal so i guess i checked
that box
anti-black no anti-hispanic no
anti-asian no hate
what i don't know that hate has been
redefined again to mean just about
any conservative movement so gosh
even i'm a pretty moderate guy and i
check all those but i guess
i guess we should all be pretty worried
about now maybe you don't use paypal
i don't really use paypal that much but
i strongly suspect this is just the shot
across the bow
i strongly suspect that pretty soon
this one financial institution is going
to
add on to it you know some more
financial institutions and that pretty
soon
you will be ostracized if you in any way
descend from the dominant leftist regime
which brings me to ben's new book the
authoritarian moment which drops
today ben is doing a live stream book
signing tonight 7
30 eastern 6 30 central dailywire.com
ben shapiro youtube ben shapiro facebook
page you can order your limited edition
signed book right now for just 30 bucks
at dailywire.com ben you can submit a
question when you go to purchase your
signed copy ben may answer it during the
live signing that's dailywire.com
ben to get your signed copy today be
sure to tune in to the live signing
tonight 7 30 eastern 6
30 central and mark your calendars
because tomorrow we're gonna be doing a
special episode of backstage with
special guest candace owens
we'll be discussing how communism keeps
trying to work its way into the american
society so do not miss it
we'll be right back with a lot more
paypal is teaming up with a radical
leftist organization
to decide whether or not you get to use
a financial service
and if the radical leftist organization
doesn't like your politics which it's so
broadly defines
a hate movement that basically anyone
could fall into it
if you're in any way on the right that
they could prevent you from using a
financial service and i suspect more
companies are going to sign on to this
i was thinking the other day about how
america we all boast
we all boast about our freedom you know
we say gosh you know in china
communist china they they have something
called a social credit score oh my gosh
how dystopian is this
in china you will be rated for your
opinions and the people you
associate with and the kind of behaviors
that you engage in
and then if your score falls too low
according to the regime
while you'll be ostracized and you'll be
prevented from
from exercising some of your rights gosh
thank goodness we live in the good old
u.s of a
where that sort of thing doesn't uh wait
a second uh oh
uh-oh sure looks familiar to me
sure looks familiar to me this is how
the regime
enforces its will not just through
big government which is the sole problem
that the right has focused on over the
past 30 years
but through big technology and through
big
corporation and through big non-profit
especially through the schools
a fourth grade teacher is in slight hot
water right now
because she passed out a radical leftist
critical race theory inspired equity
survey
and told students to hide the survey
from their parents my name is haley
osgar
i was in fourth grade at riverview
intermediate school last year
during distance learning i was asked to
complete that equity survey
my teacher said that i could not skip
any questions even when i didn't
understand
one question asked us what genderfly we
identified with
i was very confused along with a lot of
other classmates
a boy in my class asked my teacher if
his mom could explain the question to
him because
even after the teacher explained that he
still didn't understand
my teacher told him that he was not
allowed to ask his mom and that we
cannot repeat any of the questions to
her parents
i want the school board to know how
uncomfortable and nervous this made me
my mom always tells me i can tell her
anything
but she also tells me i can trust my
teachers too
being asked to hide this from my mom
made me feel very uncomfortable
i was doing like i was doing something
wrong thank you
i love it i love great job to this girl
you know very often
i i don't like it when little kids go up
and speak at the school board or speak
at the
town meeting or whatever and give some
impassioned political speech and then
people on the left and the right say wow
yes she's speaking truth to power or
whatever
because i think that kids don't really
know anything and so they shouldn't be
giving political speeches
but that's not what this girl is doing
this girl is not giving her opinion
about some political issue she is just
reporting
facts that actually were being
suppressed
by the school so the school is passing
out this
radical leftist equity survey which has
all sorts of hideous premises in it
especially on issues of race
and explicitly told
do not show this to your parents why
because the parents will object because
it's
radical leftism it's brainwashing these
kids and because the teacher believes
that the school has the exclusive right
to educate kids and parents have no
rights whatsoever
so this girl comes up good honor and
says
this is a big problem how did this
happen well the school district in
minnesota a lot of these
radical policies are coming out of
minnesota i'm noticing
in the sartell st stephen district
they hired the leftist equity alliance
minnesota
to conduct an 80 000
audit on quote racial inequities within
the school district
this according to alpha news and then
students were required to complete a
survey for the audit and parents
taxpayers were not
not permitted to know about this kind of
a survey
when the left tells you that critical
race theory is not being taught in
schools
remember this story we covered another
story like this yesterday what the
schools are doing
is they're going out and they are hiring
critical race theorists
they are hiring people who are operating
very much within
the legal analytical framework of
critical race theory
to go in and rewrite curricula in
schools and they're paying
these people handsomely to do it and
then your kids are being taught
the products of that revision that
is happening do not let them gaslight
you now
while the regime is pushing its
radicalism through the schools through
the nonprofits through
the private businesses through
everything
some people are pushing back against
these bureaucrats great story and it's
not really being reported on coming out
of atlantic city
but but it really highlights the the
political conflict we've got right now
atlantic city has had a needle exchange
needle exchanges
are generally speaking liberal policies
where you tell drug addicts to show up
to a place they can shoot up they can do
drugs
but they've just got to get clean
needles you know and so it gives it
prevents the spread
theoretically prevents the spread of
certain diseases but it still encourages
these
drug drug addicts to continue doing
drugs they just have to do it in a
slightly more controlled environment
so jersey atlantic city one of the more
degenerate cities in the country though
i love it very much i used to go there a
lot when i was a kid and you know
coming from new york you go to the
jersey shore a lot so i've got a really
soft spot in my heart for ac
not the greatest town in the world they
shut down the needle exchange after a
spike in deaths from drug overdoses
the oasis drop-in center serves 1200
drug addicts it's the only syringe
service site
in the atlantic city area it's the only
place where can you imagine how awful
it's the only place where druggies can
go in and get
more needles to shoot up with it's being
closed after a 7-2 city council vote
the decision was very unpopular among
public health professionals
the public health professionals said
look it's it's much better in our
estimation
for drug addicts to come in they're
going to keep doing drugs and destroying
their lives
but they'll get clean needles to do it
with and the citizens of the place
and their representatives on the city
council said no
because we're the only needle site
so all the druggies are coming in from
all the surrounding areas and they're
bringing a lot of crime and they're
bringing a lot of drug overdoses
to our city i mean this is the job i was
at a bachelor party in
atlantic city once and we were joking
about how we'd have to to try to jump
over the needles on the beach because
you didn't want to accidentally get
stuck
that is how bad the drug problem is in
atlantic city
so the the the debate here was over
what is best for the community and the
public health professionals were looking
only in this very narrow lane of
it is best to reduce the spread of
certain diseases
if we subsidize the drug use by giving
new needles
but the political community was looking
at the much broader question
what's better for crime what's better
for how we live
together what's better for the overall
functioning of our community be it on
the economic level and the social level
what's better for kids what's better
what's better for everybody
that was the battle that should have
taken place during kovit but
unfortunately it didn't
because we in our political community
handed over all the reins to the society
to this one group of bureaucrats and so
the only thing that was said to matter
was the spread of this one wuflu of the
of the covid cough
we neglected the economy we neglected
our civil rights we neglected our
traditions we re
we neglected civic associations we
neglected the church we neglected
everything else when president trump had
his press conferences
it shouldn't have been the dr fauci hour
or the dr scarf era
it should have been the economic adviser
the military advisor
the civil liberties advisor the
everybody everybody there to say well no
okay you get you gain a little here you
lose a little here so kudos to atlantic
city
for reasserting an authentically
political
understanding the non-profits though
speaking of civil liberties by the way
the aclu one of the more ironically
named organizations in the country
most of these non-profits with often
with ironic names are just going to
enforce
the whims of the dominant regime so the
aclu right now is going after the second
amendment
you can do it the american civil
liberties union is now trying to
undermine your second amendment rights
the bill of rights the aclu tweets that
racism
racism is foundational to the second
amendment
and its inclusion in the bill of rights
learn
more from experts carol anderson and
charles howard candler on this episode
of their podcast
there was a time when the aclu would
defend a very expansive view of the
first amendment or the second amendment
or
our entire bill of rights but that
doesn't happen now the aclu
and i didn't even like the aclu then
they were always on the left
but now the regime is insisting on this
very narrow understanding of its
priorities and so the aclu is going to
follow suit
it is not enough to fight against big
government you've got to fight against
big government
big tech big business big non-profit a
lot of the time one of the
one of the most effective ways that
america projects
its empire around the world is through
non-profits and even within the united
states
and the the worst thing that you can
possibly be labeled in this country is
racist racism is the new synonym for sin
and it's supposed to comprise all forms
of sin so they say the second
amendment's racist you gotta get rid of
the second amendment
speaking of racism the cleveland indians
have changed their name there this has
been
up for a while now either remember the
redskins had to change their name and
the indians have to change their name
and the reds have to change their name
and you'd always poll actual indians
feather not dot
and they would say we don't care we
don't we want
we want more money we want more
opportunity but we don't care about the
stupid
baseball team name but the left focus is
on the baseball team name it is now it
is racist to have your team called the
indians
so they've changed the name to the
guardians and for some reason
tom hanks is here to tell us about it we
remember those moments
as we move forward with change you see
it has always been cleveland
that's the best part of our name
and now it's time to unite as one family
one community to build the next era for
this team
and this city to keep watch and guard
what makes this game the greatest
to come together and welcome all who
want to join us
we are loyal and proud and resilient
we protect what we've earned and always
defend it
together we stand with all who
understand what it means to be born
and built from the land because this is
the city we love
and the game we believe in and together
we are all cleveland guardians
[Music]
the guardians it's a little clever
because it keeps the sound at least at
the end of the name and then the
syllables
okay you notice anything strange about
that ad
well if you were listening one strange
thing is why is tom hanks the single
whitest man ever born i think in the
entire world
why is he narrating this if the whole
thing is about how whites were racist
against the indians
okay that's one question and if you were
watching it something you might notice
a bit strange as far as i can tell there
aren't any indians in the commercial
the whole point was we have wronged the
indians
and now we're going to make it up to
them by changing the name
wouldn't you you'd expect the ad to be
about indians but it's not
there's white people and there's black
people and there's some
hispanic people i think sort of a margin
call from but
as far as i can tell there's no there's
no indians
which is the theme here when
establishment liberalism enforces itself
through
political correctness through these new
speech codes through
calling anything it doesn't like racist
what it does
is it does not give new privileges to
the indians for instance
it just erases them so where once
indians native americans were
represented and present in the cleveland
baseball team now they're gone
they're just gone they're just erased
they are no more the lando likes butter
lady remember there's a native american
woman illustrated by a native american
woman by the way
she was sitting on a plot of land on the
butter well now she's been
erased but they kept the land they got
rid of the indian and they kept the land
the story of the ages
isn't it and this is supposed to be woke
and politically correct
just erase all the indians it's not just
the indians aunt jemima aunt jemima
is a black character performed by a
black actress
created by a black comedian billy
cursands
erased by almost certainly some white
marketing lady
at the at the syrup company
completely erased now it's just the
syrup now it's just
old-timey syrup this is ironically the
effect
is to homogenize everything remove any
cultural eccentricity any any diversity
whatsoever
all in the name of anti-racism
just erasing this is pretty funny there
are it is it's sad but it's fun there
are some funny aspects
to this inane and bizarre
leftist racial ideology
i think the funniest turn of events
in the new racial identity ideology or
the latest stage of the racial identity
ideology on the left
is the racial advocacy pledge that just
came out of a group called
dallas justice now i love this i want to
frame this letter i love it so much it's
it's a letter written to white libs
who go along with this radical leftist
racial group
to our white allies this is an open
letter to wealthy white liberals
of hpisd from from dallas justice now i
guess from the school district to dallas
justice now
talk is not enough commit yourself
towards
taking action and making sacrifices to
correct centuries of injustice
open up spaces for black and latinx
communities
by refusing just this is so
by refusing to send your kids to ivy
league
and u.s news and world report top 50
schools and encourage friends
neighbors and family members to do the
same imagine if those hundreds of
thousands of spots at these institutions
were occupied only by marginalized
communities
imagine the opportunities we can achieve
true equity within our lifetimes
but only if white folks are willing to
sacrifice their privileges thank you
that when i first saw this
i was certain that dallas justice now
was just a right-wing op like it was
just a joke
because the point is oh great hey you
white libs who post the black square
and you show up in the streets and you
you pretend to care about this stuff
cool don't send your kid to the ivy
league because your kids
are going to the ivy league at higher
rates because statistically they get
better sat scores
and even maybe because they're better
connected or maybe you're donating to
the schools or whatever
but even if it's just the sat scores so
if your kids don't apply
then that won't be as big of a problem
and then our kids will get to go
so you're going to do that right because
you're an ally because you you really
care about this stuff
you're going to these white libs
in not just this school district but
wealthy white libs
and and middle to up middle upper middle
class white libs
in every school district across this
country would crawl over broken glass
to secure their child a spot at harvard
yale
princeton dartmouth penn columbia
brown any of those schools would crawl
truly would do anything do you remember
the laurie laughlin
or lost what's her name the one who she
she
paid a bunch of money to fake her kids
credentials so she could get into
like usc or something i mean this this
is the obsession
that these white libs have with sending
their kids to the prestigious schools
and this racial advocacy group says okay
you really care about us cool then give
up that thing that you really like
and then it doesn't just end there so
you've got you've got the
carrot right you've got the enticement
to do this where you'll be an ally it'll
be so great but then you've got the
stick
so they write about the racial advocacy
then they say okay so you've got to then
take the pledge i will not do this i
will not send my
kid to whatever and if you do not do
this
you will be doxxed so the racial
dallas justice now says they will
publish the names
of the parents who who do not sign the
pledge
so you got to sign the pledge because
otherwise you'll be docked you'll be
threat obviously after this the summer
of hate last year you'll be threatened
with violence
and you might have your home burned down
so sign the pledge
hey he lives this is the this is the
world you wanted so
so sign the pledge something tells me
they're not going to do that
it's just but it maybe they will because
they're afraid of having their homes and
their businesses burned down
so much of the this
radical ideology being pushed not just
by the fringes but by the regime itself
is not a matter of argumentation and
logic it's just a matter of brute force
do this or i'm going to come to your
home and i'm going to throw you in a car
and i'm going to stick you with a needle
right go do this or i'm going to come
over i'm going to publish the name of
your house and
roving mobs that burned our country down
last year are going to come after you
too
aoc was just on don lemon's show on cnn
and aoc said it's very important not
just to
fact check republicans but
to confront their core logic
so congresswoman i want to ask you about
this debate that we're seeing over
critical race theory do you think
republican efforts to redefine it
and use it as a scare tactic do you
think it's working
well i do think it's working because
what we have seen
is that the republican-based republican
party has really pivoted to a strategy
of using race and using just the
changing demographics of this country
and as we saw on january 6 using a white
supremacist
core logic in order to reanimate
a very core fear in this country of the
other
and so what's really important is that
we
come together and have a very
strong rebuttal to that core logic
not just in fact checking republican
claims
but actually confronting the core logic
and addressing the core fears that they
are trying to really tap into when they
try to use terms like critical race
theory
as a proxy for just saying talking about
race in schools in general
so she makes actually a good point she
makes a bunch of stupid points but she
makes
a good point here it's it's also worth
noting i don't want to let this
get away the left always tells us that
if you believe that there is an
intentional effort
to change the demographics of this
country that it's a conspiracy theory
and it's white supremacist and it's
crazy and yet aoc is
admitting it here she's saying that yes
there is an effort underway to change
the demographics of this country we're
doing it
and if you complain about it you're a
white supremacist too so if you think
it's a
it's real you're a white supremacist if
we then tell you it's real and you
object in any way you're white
supremacist just wanted to point that
out
but what she says here is it's not
enough to fact check
republicans because you have to confront
their core logic and she just keeps
saying core lot whatever that means
logic is logic it's not it's not your
logic and my logic and his logic there
is logic
right and we use logic to make arguments
to one another
so when you fact check you are checking
the person's logic the logical
progressions that they have made
and you can also check their premises
and you can
okay fine what aoc is
observing though is she can't fact check
the republicans because on the on the
facts republicans are right
generally speaking on on whatever the
issue of the day
is okay generally speaking the
republicans
are more likely to be right than the
democrats so she said remember when she
said well i'm not factually right but
i'm morally right
not factually correct but i'm morally
right so you're saying yeah we can't
check their facts but we can confront
their core logic meaning
logic itself the whole point of these of
these
new leftist theories is we're going to
argue against
logic there is no objective truth there
is no faculty of reason
the phrase objective truth itself is a
white supremacist dog whistle
and so we've got to confront that that
is what not just critical race theory
but
postmodernism so deconstruction so many
of these
of these leftist arguments are about
imposing one's tyranny of will
absent any kind of logical argument
that's an offer you can't refuse because
they're going to make it with their
fists i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico associate producer justine
turley
audio mixer mike coromina and hair and
makeup
by nika geneva michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 john bickley
here
editor-in-chief of daily wire wake up
every morning with our new show
morning wire on today's show the justice
department decides not to investigate
nursing home deaths in 2020
house democrats assemble a january 6th
committee and tensions rise as u.s
diplomats sit down with chinese
officials
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with
our show morning wire